كشفت صحيفه يدعو حر نوت الاسرائيليه عن
ايداع اول دعوه مدنيه بشان هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر وقد رفعها ضد الجيش والشرطه
والشباك 42 من ضحايا حفل نوفا وقالت
الصحيفه ان الدعوه تتضمن اتهامات بالتقصير
والاهمال والسماح بتنظيم الحفل رغم وجود
تنبيهات بشان حادث امني خطير جاءت قبل
ساعات في تقييمين للجيش واض ان الدعوه
تذكر ان اتصالا هاتفيا واحدا كان كفيلا
بتفريق المشاركين في الحفل وتجنب ما وصفته
بالمجزر كما اشارت الدعوه الى علم الشباك
بوجود خطر مع وجود عدد قليل من ضباط
الشرطه الذين لا يتناسب تسليحهم مع
المنطقه المتاخمه لغزه وفق
الصحيفه في الاثناء افادت صحيفتها ريتس
بان اسرائيل قررت المثول امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه في لاهاي لدفاع عن نفسها في اطار
الدعوه المرفوعه ضدها من جنوب افريقيا
والتي تطالب بوقف اطلاق النار في غزه
وتتهم اسرائيل بارتكاب جرائم اباده في غزه
تاتي الخطوه الاسرائيليه المرتقبه من اجل
الحيلوله دون اصدار المحكمه قرارا قضائيا
مؤقتا ضد اسرائيل يطالبها بالتعليق الفوري
لعملياتها العسكريه في
غزه معنا من رام الله الدكتور احمد الاشقر
استاذ القانون والعلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه الامريكيه اهلا بك دكتور احمد هل
من شان بالفعل هذه الخطوه بقرار المثول
امام المحكمه ان يحول دون اصدار قرار من
محكمه العدل الدوليه فيما يتعلق بوقف
اطلاق فوري
للنار بكل تاكيد هذا لا يحول ليس بالضروره
ان اسرائيل وافقت على المثول امام محكمه
العدده الدوليه ان ذلك سيؤدي الى يعني
عرقله اصدار القرار الذي يعني يمكن ان
يتضمن وقف فوري لاطلاق النار ضمن اطار
بروتوكول التدابير المؤقته التي يمكن ان
تتخذها المحكمه اسرائيل ملزمه بالمناسبه
في المثول لان هي اصلا عضو في اتفاقيه
الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب عليها الموقع
في سنه 48 وهي تحاول عبر هذه الخطوه ان
تضع يعني العراقيل امام اصدار هذا القرار
عبر تقديم دفاعها بهذا الش واعتقد جازما
ان يعني هذا س سيبوء بالفشل بكل تاكيد لكن
ال يعني هذه خطوه متقدمه ان دوله الاحتلال
الكيان الصهيوني الان اصبح ملزما بان يقف
امام اي جهه قضائيه دوليه وان يتحدث وان
يحاول على الاقل ان يقول ما ما يجب قوله
في هذا الاطار والذي يجب قوله وقف هذا
العدوان والاباده الجماعيه على الشعب
الفلسطيني التي ترتكب في ظل صمت واضح
ويعني غير مبرر من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه من الادعاء العام على وجه التحديد
ربما تكون خطووه دوله جنوب افريقيا هي
معزز كبير ل باتجاه الضغط على كريم خان من
اجل تحريك يعني ملفات التحقيق التي ثبتت
كل اوجه الادله وحتى بحضوره امام معبر رفح
وا يعني مشاهدته لكم الجرائم التي ارتكبت
واهمها منع الغذاء والطعام والماء والدواء
عن سكان المحاصرين في قطاع غزه المدنيين
الذين يقتلون و يقصفون وبالتالي هذا
المثول لدوله الاحتلال هو اجباري بحكم ان
هي دوله عضو في هيئه الامم المتحده وعضو
في اتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه والمعاقب
عليها لكن ما يهمنا في هذا الاطار ان لا
تتوانى او تتاخر المحكمه وهي منعقده بهذا
الوقت يعني من العام انلا تتاخر في اصدار
التدبير المؤقت باذن باذن الله ان شاء
الله المتضمن وقف فوري لاطلاق النار وانا
هنا لا اتحدث فقط عن وقف فوري فيما يتعلق
بالعمليات الحربيه التي تقوم بها لا هي كل
ما يهدد الجماعه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
وفي الوصفه الغربيه يجب ان تتوقف دوله
الاحتلال عن اتخاذ هذه الاجراءات وبالتالي
مجرد المثول اذا هي قبلت دوله الاحتلال
بانها هي خاضعه
وملتزمه المفروض بما يصدر عن هذه المحكمه
من قرارات املا ان تكون محكمه العدد
الدوليه وهي بالمناسبه محكمه دول وليس
محكمه افراد ان تقوم باصدار هذا القرار
على وجه السرعه حمايه ل المدنيين
الفلسطينيين الذين يقتلون كل يوم طيب
لنوضح اكثر هذه النقطه الخاصه بالالزام
مثول اسرائيل هو الزامي كما ذكرت كونها
موقعه على هذه الاتفاقيه ولكن الزامها
بقرارات محكمه العدل الدوليه الى اي مدى
هو امر لا مفر
منه يعني انا باعتقادي انه لا يوجد ادوات
تنفيذيه الا من خلال مجلس الامن وبالتالي
نحن نعرف الوضعيه في مجلس الامن مع ظل مع
في ظل وجود يعني الفيتو الامريكي دائما
المسان لاسرائيل ولكن قرار المحكمه باتخاذ
هذه التدابير هو يشكل التزاما اخلاقيا عبر
التجارب التي مرت بها هذه المحكمه اسرائيل
ستكون ملزمه وستكون محرجه في حال عدم
قيامها بتنفيذ ما يصدر عن هذه المحكمه
سيما وانها الان قبلت المثول امام هذه
المحكمه وقبلت ب ولايتها القضائيه وهذا
يحملها المسؤوليه الدوليه بشكل كبير
ويضعها في بشكل يعني بصراحه وكانها يعني
اي دوله خارج اطار القانون الدولي وهذا
سيعزز حتى صدور هذا القرار وعدم تنفيذه
سيعزز من قدره المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والمطالبين طيب دكتور اح في ان تتحرك هذه
المحكمه باتجاه في اسوى سيناريوهات ان تم
استخدام دكتور احمد في اسوى سيناريوهات تم
استخدام الفيتو الامريكي ما الذي سيجري من
الناحيه القانونيه هل سيكفي الاحراج يعني
اسرائيل لا يحرجها شيء فيما تقوم به من
افعال لا لا لا بكل بكل تاكيد لا يكفي
الاحراج ولكن نحن نتحدث عن معادله القانون
الدولي وتحديدا في
موضوع محكمه العدل الدوليه ان هي احدى
مؤسسات الامم المتحده لكن المهم فيما
سيصدر من هذا القرار انه سيشكل ترسانه
مهمه جدا باتجاه محاكمه الافراد ا دوله
الكيان الاسرائيلي في حال عدم التزامهم
بقرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه سيكون
لزاما على كريم خان ان يقوم بتحريك الدعوه
وان لا يقف صامتا امام كل ذلك انا
باعتقادي انه هذا المنتظم الدولي هذه
المحكمه الدوليه وهي اهم محكمه دوليه
بالمناسبه وهي تتمتع بنوع من الاحترام
الكبير لدى كافه وهي تعيد صياغه مبادئ
القانون الدولي عدم الالتزام بقراراتها
سيرتب اثرا كبيرا باتجاه تحميل المسؤوليه
الدوليه دوله الاحتلال من جهه وللافراح
بمعنى انه هناك اصرار على استمرار الاباده
وهناك مجموعه من الجرائم الحرب التي ترتكب
كل يوم منها بالمناسبه الاباده الجماعيه
لكن هناك جرائم موصوفه في ايضا نظام رؤب
الاساس المنشي للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
سيكون قرار المحكمه ونامل ان تصل الى هذه
المرحله ليس فقط مخرجا لاسرائيل وانما
ملزما لها وقد يكون اصلا مخرجا لدوله مرح
كل هذه الايضاحات القانونيه نشكرك من رام
الله الدكتور احمد الاشقر استاذ العلوم
القانون والعلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
الامريكيه